each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon how it's my great
pleasure to introduce professor Romania
duraisamy and Adam o Donovan to give a
talk audio cameras for audio visual
scene analysis professor Romanie
duraiswamy is an associate professor in
the department of computer science and
the institute for advanced computer
studies at the University of Maryland
College Park he obtained his a bachelor
of technology degree from IIT Bombay and
PhD from Johns Hopkins University he
can't redirects research at the
perceptual interface and reality
laboratory at the University of Maryland
his current research interest can
broadly include areas in audio for
virtual reality human-computer
interaction and scientific computing
such as multi core GPU stuff and the
computational machine learning and a
vision so Adam Adam o Donovan is a PhD
candidate and graduate research
assistant at a department of computer
science at the University of Maryland he
has BS degree in physics and computer
science from Maryland he received the
nvidia fellowship for 208 and 209 and
university of maryland prime fellowship
in 207 to 208 he has been interning in a
couple of places including microsoft
research that was last year I was yes so
without further ado let's welcome thank
you Joe
so I am going to talk about some recent
work we've been doing in and device we
developed which we call the audio camera
and so so a goal the goal of our
research I guess it's a bit clouds or
move it down the goal of our research is
essentially doing scene understanding
and as well as sort of capturing scenes
and reproducing them for remote remote
listening either sort of
contemporaneously or sort of for later
listening and of course if you want to
understand scenes and sort of you it's
quite often much more advantageous to
use both the visual information and the
auditory information because audio and
vision often provide a sort of
complementary information and it's
because sound travels relatively slowly
and it's sort of its able to capture
lots of information in its time varying
signal on the other hand light is sort
of very good for geometric and
information because it's sort of
pinpoint and so on but on the other hand
sound sort of does not suffer as much
from occlusion as light so there's lots
of information in both and often if you
use both modalities you get more bang
for your buck so the kind of information
people want to capture it of sound is of
course speech and sort of non-speech art
references but and there is sort of a
tremendous amount of work which has gone
on in speech and speech recognition
automatic speech recognition and so on
but most of that is sort of with close
stocking speech so speech captured by
microphones right next to you but
there's other information in sound so
for example where the source comes from
and this includes both the
direction and the range of the source
and the sound information which you
receive in a room or out outdoors often
also captures information about the
ambience it has information about the
reverberant structure the materials of
the room the size of the room and so on
all that information is available in the
sound which you receive and if you have
the knowledge and location of the
ambience of the source location end of
the room ambience that can also help you
and sort of get extracting the
information no sort of improving speech
processing if you have sort of distant
collection okay so sort of a broad theme
of our research is combining microphone
arrays and cameras and what we like to
think is that are in our approach to
doing especially the oddly audio
processing part of our work we differ
from many previous many previous authors
in the sense that especially as far as
audio is concerned when audio and video
processing are done together usually
they're done separately and integrations
sort of happen between audio and video
after the processing modality sort of
you've completed your job in both
modalities then you sort of fuse results
so in especially in this work what we
try to do is we try to treat the audio
also as a geometry sensor and thus as a
camera and try to treat audio and video
in a joint analysis framework so so this
is sort of lots of tall claims made
initially so let's sort of see what we
want to do here so so as I mentioned one
of our sort of interest is source
localization and when we do source
localization via audio
you want to use microphone arrays and
there are many approaches to doing
source localization using microphone
arrays and the the oldest techniques are
based on solving sort of geometrical
nonlinear estimation problems so
essentially you you know time delays of
arrivals for example between sources
between microphones and you try to solve
for the source location by solving some
nonlinear estimation problem but this
approach especially in the presence of
noise and reverberations is known to be
inaccurate and another way which people
have used in the literature is by doing
sort of looking at what's called steered
response power so the idea is you use
your your microphone array and you
hypothesize that there is a source at
some given location you steer your
microphone to point at a particular
location and if your hypothesis is
correct you get some gain in the signal
received and then you sort of repeat
this test and sort of look procedure for
many many different locations and if you
then so choose you can sort of display
this image this sequence of of beams
steered as an image and you end up with
an intensity image of sound arriving
from particular points in space and of
course this approach is interesting
because it's sort of less prone to noise
and potentially more accurate and
moreover you can incorporate a priority
constraints so the disadvantage is your
costs rise as the number of look
locations increase because essentially
you have to sum up all the microphone
signals multiply them by certain weights
and potentially if you are doing a
frequency-dependent algorithm you have
to do it separately for each frequency
and this gets extremely expensive
so so this is I'm still sort of staying
in an introductory phase now what I'm
going to do is we're going to do this
we're going to follow this approach
we're going to do beamforming and we go
into sort of point beams at many many
directions but we are going to use a
special microphone setup and this is the
spherical microphone array so the
spherical microphone array is an is an
interesting object essentially what we
have is you have a spherical solid
surface and this spherical solid surface
you can sort of imagine on its surface
there are a bunch of of microphones or
in an ideal case you have a sort of a
pressure-sensitive surface and it turns
out that for this surface you can use
the principle of acoustic reciprocity
and you can very easily construct beam
patterns for any arbitrary look
direction so suppose you have a plane
wave arriving from a particular
direction say theta K and fee k you can
solve the equation for sort of sound
scattering of the surface of the sphere
and you can get the solution for the
scattered sound field which is sort of
given here and this gives you
essentially for a given plane wave what
the the sound received at any point on
the surface of the sphere would be so
that would be the sound which would be
recorded by a microphone which would be
placed flush on the surface of the of
the array and in acoustics there's this
wonderful principle it's also there in
light which is called Helmholtz
reciprocity just knowing this solution
you can also automatically find what the
beamformer weights would be to sort of
to do beam forming in
this direction theta k and PK so
essentially you can find the weights of
x which you need to multiply the
recorded signals to get back the to get
the response in a particular direction
sigh theta k fek so so the nice thing
about this structure is that the the
beamformer weights can be sort of
factored in a way that you can get
essentially a beam pattern which looks
like spherical harmonics so what are
spherical harmonics so spherical
harmonics are just like sort of food
they're Fourier series on the surface of
a sphere so in two dimensions just like
regular Fourier series are sort of a
basis on the circle spherical harmonics
are sort of doubly periodic functions
which form a basis on the surface of the
sphere and essentially any square
integrable function on the surface of a
sphere can be expanded in a series in
terms of spherical harmonics these these
harmonics looks so you have one
frequency parameter for Fourier series
for spherical harmonics you have two
frequency parameters so in one direction
sort of you increase the frequency in
this way so essentially this is not
south along the latitude and in the
second as you sort of increase the
second index you have along the azimuth
the the order of the CD is increasing
okay and any function can be expanded in
terms of spherical harmonics and you can
get so because now the spherical array
you know the weights corresponding to
get a spherical harmonic beam pattern in
a particular direction you can now
essentially compute automatically
the beam pattern for any particular
shape you'd like for the beam and this
is sort of a gratuitous plug for our
book which I throw in a couple of times
in every talk so had to push the sales
up again okay so now let's sort of step
back and see how you do spherical
arabian forming so suppose you want to
find the beam response of this array in
some particular direction theta and
you've sort of recorded signals now at s
microphones which is spread on the
surface of the sphere you compute these
weights and use a you sum up and you get
the response in in that particular
direction and these weights themselves
in general are sort of an infinite set
of is they involve an infinite summation
but since you you will not have any so
that would correspond to the case where
you actually had an infinity of
microphones on the surface of the sphere
as opposed to us a finite set s so
instead you have to sort of truncate the
this some at some number n minus 1 which
is related to this number of microphones
s you have and so that is related to
them out to the number of microphones
you have and this order n minus 1 so so
the number of coefficients you end up
with this sort of proportional to the
number of microphones you have so
suppose you had 64 microphones you could
sort of end up for you truncate you
truncate here at and so that's 0 through
7 so you have eight so you have 64
coefficients so the
the we we did some sort of improvements
to the original work of elko which sort
of N and Myers which created the
spherical rape and Elko n so this is
related to some technical issues
involving quadrature on the surface of
the sphere Elko and Myers used
particular designs for this spherical
arrays which required you to place the
microphones at the locations of of
particular platonic solids on the
surface of the sphere and this was
related to how you could sort of perform
quadrature on the surface of the sphere
so the microphones had to be at the
locations where you could perform
quadrature on the sphere but it it
turned out that their locations of the
microphones if even one or two
microphones failed you have problems and
you can't do beamforming with these
arrays we a previous PhD student of mine
Z only developed sort of general uniform
layouts on the surface of the microphone
array he's also at Microsoft I should
have realized and coheir and but he's in
the libe and in your group i guess that
i should i should have called him but
anyway so he developed this theory of
quadrature on the surface of the sphere
and using some previous work by Lord
Thompson where he sort of was trying to
develop a theory of electrons on the
surface of a sphere and had them all
repelling each other and it turns out
that if you use these as your locations
of the microphones you get you get
robustness with respect to quadrature
area and so then a few years ago then Z
own built the sphere where he
essentially took a lampshade and he put
a bunch of microphone
at the locations corresponding to what
this quadrature problem gave him and we
then proceeded to use this array for
vary for different thing and here are
some pictures of his which show that if
these four microphones are missing he
still gets good quadrature era yep so
essentially this arrangement so the
thing is what happens is this summation
corresponds to an integral over the
surface of the sphere and these weights
so the the location of these of these
theta s if you remember from sort of
your numerical methods thing usually
when you do a quadrature over some
interval if you choose your locations of
your quadrature nodes so for example
people choose chebyshev nodes along the
line and they get better thing so just
like you have some special nodes these
nodes are selected to sort of minimize
quadrature rata basis yeah yeah so
they're sort of somehow optimally far
from each other in some in some sense
okay so so we so then we proceeded to
build different arrays and so these are
actual experimental beam patterns
obtained with these arrays so this is an
order five beam pattern so this is a
main lobe and this is we built also a
hemispherical array so this is this was
for a video conferencing application so
where we place the hemisphere on a table
and you get the sphere is completed by
the image of the hemisphere on the
surface of the in the surface of the
table so you get for free you get a
double the number of microphones because
of the image principle
and with the same number of microphones
you are able to get much higher order
beam patterns so this is an eighth order
beam pattern which is relatively tight
this is amol microphones Oh pricing the
in the optimal because you're right now
verses from the line right house okay do
you game oh so ballpark okay so if you
have 60 for microphones you can so get
an eighth order beam pattern so you can
get sort of an n-fold improve square
root of number of microphones
improvement in the gain of the
microphone array using this fear okay so
and we also use them to sort of track
traffic as they went along sort of a
point it along and sort of take it along
and so on but now we sort of get to the
the subject of the stock what we wanted
to do with this microphone array was to
use it for audio imaging so which is
sort of return to the first theme which
I mentioned so suppose I now we use this
microphone array and this is a source in
a room say someone speaking and we
essentially digitally steer the beam at
many angles and at many azimuths so
essentially at any so at this direction
at this direction at this direction and
so on and make a map of the energy which
is received you do so this is a Mercator
projection so this is like the sort of
Earth's map which is put out so
essentially that the top one spot is
spread out so just like Antarctica and
the Arctic are spread out in the real
world you have a spread out location so
this is this person but you can also see
all his reverberations in that room as
he speaking because of the structure of
this image so so now our goal is to use
the spherical microphone array and
create a
vice which can create this kind of image
continuously in at frame rates and then
use it to reason about the structure of
audio scenes yeah so what we see besides
the main image yeah those kind of likes
blue spots what is these those are the
sidewalks or those are actual reflection
those are actual reflections there there
will be some side lobe contamination
also but the side lobes are relatively
weak in this in this array so that there
is some so that is like a point spread
function of a camera there will be some
spreading but most of these actually you
can reason and you can figure out that
these are actually the reflections the
lower participation from the floor
ceiling and also from the vaults right
and so we essentially transform the
spherical array into a camera for sound
ok I will come in one second so so what
is the processing essentially we I will
sort of this is too many words so
essentially we have a ray from the
center of the camera in the look
direction and we have that energy there
and that is somehow spread by the beam
pattern and side lobes also but mainly
it is sort of from that particular
direction and we create the image ok so
then we came with an interesting
observation that this image is what is
called a central projection image so to
those of you who have taken a computer
vision course you know this is sort of a
the first thing you learn about when you
learn about imaging models that the
image model which is used for cameras is
that it's a central projection camera
image so all rays of light pass through
this camera center which is the image
center and this forms the basis for the
geometric
Alice's of video of images and you
essentially can use the tools of
projective geometry to analyze images
okay so now we the images which we are
producing with this audio camera also
have this central projection property
essentially all the Rays are going
through the center of the of the sphere
which is the imaging sphere and because
of this we can essentially we have the
epipolar geometry so suppose now I image
a scene using both an audio camera so
which is this guy here and a video
camera then there is an epi polar
geometry between the audio camera and
the video camera so essentially suppose
this is this person p is being viewed by
the video camera you can and let's say p
happens to be a phase detector which is
run you on the video camera so now you
know when i look at the audio camera
image that person can't be absolutely
anywhere but in fact they have to lie
somewhere along this line in the audio
camera space okay and you can use such
constraints between two cameras between
three cameras and so on and you can
borrow this from vision and moreover now
if I have two cameras and I know the
correspondence at seven or eight points
in the world then I have i can compute
what's called a fundamental matrix
between these two cameras and which then
allows us for any new points to find the
AP polar line corresponding to this in
the other image so of course when you
have cameras you do calibration so we
built a calibration target so this is a
pencil which has a tiny speaker and a
tiny light source at the end of it and
we simultaneously image it using the
audio and video camera this is supposed
to be an animation so somehow the jif
is not animating but anyway and then you
can sort of get the epipolar lines so
which is sort of shown here between the
two cameras and so here is the epipolar
line from the sound camera sort of
displays in the audio image in the video
image and you can see the it's sort of
passing through the light source light
source and the sound source which our
school located so now I we want to
create these images in real time right
so we need to do some processing to
create this images in real time so the
nice thing is of course this beamforming
is digital the weights are known
explicitly for each direction I don't
have to I can sort of just use the
formula each direction the beamforming
is independent and there is some sort of
it's some math you can either do it
using time domain signals or frequency
domain signals depending upon your
application but this is sort of
relatively expensive they requires this
sort of computer each pixel so in light
we are very lucky each pixel essentially
gets almost for free the image from a
particular ray but this is like if you
had a camera and you had to sort of sum
up all the pixels outputs to get what is
for a particular direction this is
what's happening with the sound camera
so now we have an expensive computation
and yeah we can do it for each frequency
but there is also a time domain
formulation we can do if which which can
save up something I didn't go into that
but there is a way to do it in time
domain but in usually we do it frequency
by frequency because the frequency
representation gives us more interesting
ways of doing things I'll come to that
in a second so we need to somehow speed
this up and get it running at frame rate
to produce video images so of course we
can use parallel ism
and it turns out that the first set up
which sort of people did with this with
this trying to do this beamforming they
were doing too many extra computations
which were not necessary and we could
use some special function tricks to
reduce the number of computations so it
turns out that there was an inner sum
which involves some aspherical harmonics
and this inner some it turns out we can
use what's called the spherical harmonic
addition theorem and reduce this sort of
n special function evaluations actually
to end special function evaluations in
this sort of summation into just one
evaluation of the Legendre polynomial ad
for one angle cosine of gamma and this
these cosine gap so this essentially
correspond to the angle between the
microphone location and the look
direction so if we have a table of look
directions we can just sort of store
these angles corresponding to sort of
specific look directions in a table and
we don't need to in fact do this special
function evaluation all the time why NMR
the spherical harmonic functions which I
sort of short a few slides ago so it
reduces M multiplying ads to just one
cosine evaluation and it turns out that
there was another sort of complicated
function and I which is here this guy
here and it turns out that if you sort
of go back to look at sort of ordinary
differential equation theory which one
learns there is a an expression called
the wronskian and so which takes sort of
functions which are sort of Bessel
functions which correspond to J and H
and their products are just a simple
it turns out is a simple polynomial and
that again that that function evaluation
can be also simplified and of course
then we can use parallel processing so
now you have we've reduced the cost of
each direction and we are going to use
the fact they're in parallel and we are
going to end in fact it's trivially
parallel to get really fast beamforming
in each direction and if you speak of
parallel you go to sort of graphics
processors and these graphics processors
so this is actually now a little bit
dated this is a couple of years old this
is the nvidia 8800 gtx and actually this
is the one we used but if you use the
later nvidia it's the speed is somewhere
here which at a teraflop now and you can
we are able to run this thing at 100
frames a second with still some
computation to spare of course Adele
doesn't or didn't use to sell these
computers when we wanted them so we had
to buy computers which had funky lights
and then from these game manufacturers
here yeah at that the resolution is
relatively coarse this is related to the
so the resolution was about ten thousand
pixels to to get for pie coverage of the
room we this was we were doing it at
about 20 frequency bands and which were
covering and I skipped i glossed over
some details so for example the lower
frequency bands you cannot do very high
order beamforming you can only do order
to an order three in hundred Hertz and
so on but as you get to the the
kilohertz range you can do higher order
beamforming which gives you sort of more
resolution images and those images which
I showed you where corresponding to the
four kilohertz band so I
that that's an important distinction
which I jumped over ok so now I'm going
to show you some images of this sort of
real-time thing so so this is the image
of how the calibration was done so he's
essentially taking maybe I in so he's
sending off the sound and at different
locations so once that's done you can do
some interesting things so once you have
the calibration done the next thing you
can do is you can do image transfer so
now with uni in the hall I'm sort of
scared to talk about image transfer but
anyway and still talk about image
transfer so suppose I have two cameras
and I assume that the world is far away
right so then just knowing the
fundamental matrix I can do image
transfer between two cameras so and so I
am going to show you so here Adam is
going to switch on a speaker so the top
is the audio image and we know the
fundamental matrix between these two
cameras so we are going to transfer the
audio image to the video image so we
switch it on and as soon as he switches
it on those pixels light up which is
where the sound is coming from and so
now we sort of go through for his
speaking he's flicking his thing and so
on and you can sort of find and you can
get an idea of the resolution so that
pixel in the regular image essentially
comes much much bigger
the false colors are actually that we
are showing a RGB images r g and b are
different frequency bands which are
mapped to the phone kasam Connor what
there is what is that spot in this
resolution that resolution is very low
as i said whole ten thousand pixels is
basically giving us for pie and this is
just a very small sort of field of view
and you're looking at this yeah a smooth
out there yeah when you talk yeah yeah
please long it's it's a as a filtering
sort of the image persists for a little
bit so that it doesn't sort of
immediately disappear happy snap
speaker
so now let me show you some more
applications so so the next application
so here we can sort of consider that
this application was essentially audio
is helping video to find out where the
sound is coming from so now let us look
for an application where video is
helping audio yeah for this you would
only have X's of rest
cadence should have like rate so this is
the point I was making that if you
assume that the world is far away and
it's on the it's on the surface both the
objects are far away then if you know
the two cameras and you assume that the
sources you can get the direction and
you can project onto this direction to
do it exactly correctly like you're
saying with the range information we
would need three cameras then we can do
sort of image transfer between three
cameras but if but this assumption
actually works we are reasonably close
they're reasonably closer and so now
then others i'm going back to the same
one okay in this application what we are
doing is we have Adam and we have so the
or the video camera and the audio camera
and there's a very loud sound source
okay and this sound sources music is
playing very loudly and we are going to
try to beam form use the epipolar
constraint to help beamforming and in
this I am going to play some sound so
essentially they're the first sort of
the sound without beamforming and you
cannot make out what Adam is saying and
then you'll just hear the sound which
was obtained by searching along the AP
poll or line for the for the peak and in
this case you will sort of be able to
make out what he's saying and there was
no sort of tricks like Yvonne users of
post filtering and all this wonderful
stuff I used if you use those that would
be even better pure being for me
now with beam forming along the people
online
that's the spherical might be no no no
no the one in the back is actually
something else totally oh it's it has to
do with head related wrong this is the
microphone oh that little whites thing
you know we have that that also is a
microphone array but that measures your
head related transfer function if you
step in but that's in the lab using
source so both are relatively the same
distance to the to the microphone so you
can also do sort of things with multiple
sources so for example we did a lot of
experiments with sort of two sources how
identifiable they are so that those are
all reported in a paper which is in the
transactions of audio processing this
it's in press how close they can be and
you can still identify how far apart and
so on okay yeah if you just really
inform you the thrashing yesterday
you're not trying to steal it no nothing
so this is very trivial beamforming
which is sort of just the main lobe okay
so the next idea was in audio most
people know that if you have a room you
get reflections from all the walls in
the room and that affects listening
quality especially in concert hall
acoustics people are very interested in
designing the concert hall so that you
have good direct path there are some
early arriving reflections which are
sort of which have to be distinct and
late arriving distinction reflect
reverberations have to be sort of
attenuated and so on and this is indeed
up sort of a black art which
architectural acousticians do so could
we use the audio camera somehow to help
architectural acousticians and so we
went and measured essentially this is a
very nice music hall which is at the
campus of the university of maryland and
this is a panoramic image of this place
and he
we have replaced a sound source on the
on the stage and this is a spherical
panorama which is sort of unwrapped here
and you can see this this whole so now
I'm going to play you a demo of a
slow-motion movie which we got so I am
going to now display the spherical
panoramas in this fashion and so now
this is on a sphere so it sort of looks
more reasonable and the sound source is
located here so so as I play this sound
it you can see the sound come off it is
a very short chirp and then you can see
the sound reflect of the walls you can
see the location of the reflections you
can see it's reflected of the floor of
the back wall and you can sort of this
is a short 10 millisecond chirp but as
you sort of keep going along you see for
several seconds essentially all the
reflections in slow motion as so you can
see for its now reached the ceiling you
can see the reflection of sound all the
locations oh by the way this just these
colors are sort of normalized so that in
each frame the maximum color is the same
is red so the maximum intensity is red
otherwise they should they would be
attenuating and you you would see sort
of damped out colors so essentially many
we've shown this to several
architectural acoustician and they are
very very excited because apparently it
takes on two months to fix a hall after
it's built and having such tools they
can sort of go and they get these things
of course we need a much more portable
audio camera to do that and we are sort
of working on that I will show that as
I'll show you in a second so
after many seconds it's still very good
coherence like it is and it's amazing to
actually go yeah it is it if I keep
going I sort of stopped it but if I sort
of take it along as time goes on you'll
sort of see it's not so there are so
many reflections all over the place as
sort of at later times that it's yeah
second it's small it's sort of it goes
this screen is not that it goes to about
to something the second so but the the
original chirp was only several
milliseconds 10 to 12 milliseconds
something else shucks yeah that's how
we're seeing this is where you something
no no it's still going on its second
every second is all voicing so much so
cylinders
and this graph on top is then dr. so
what cut off a little bit that's that
sort of a plot with the maximum value in
that particular images as a wonderful
job so that's how you see that you see
that it carries this is a hot computer
is the secondary first double tracking a
second direction oh god it's actually
difficult to identify exactly what order
a refraction yeah it's hard to identify
but now we're going to sort of come to
another use so the next goal is of
course we did this for concert hall so
can we use it in room acoustic somehow
so in room acoustics we all know sort of
reverberation is often treated as
something to be not is not not a friend
it's bad it sort of schools up by
algorithms and so on and though there
have been people since the 80s and 90s
who sort of thought of doing what's
called matched field processing so the
idea there is suppose I know the source
and I know the room impulse response
then I can potentially invert this room
impulse response and clean up the sound
field right but then so the most famous
person who sort of worked a lot on this
area as Jim Flanagan and he essentially
wrote several papers trying to do this
idea and even one of his students is
also at Microsoft but he's moved to live
labs also our search labs Arun Surendran
and they worked on this area of trying
to do basically match field processing
but what they found is even a small
error in the look in the room impulse
response essentially destroyed the
results okay so now the thought we had
was is there somewhere we can use this
this audio camera with the visual camera
to to figure out which reflections
actually obtained at the microphone
array and can be used those in some
interesting way to improve the signal
quality as well as doody reverberation
so so this is essentially what I just
said so what I'm going to do is now
going to show you this movie well that's
not that guess it didn't launch and now
it's here
or maybe I just go to the directory
whether i'll have to so it's sort of all
it's doing something
you were spoken so okay so let's I'll go
I'll show you the demo at the end when
sort of MATLAB recovers let's so what is
our algorithm so essentially what we do
is we go to a room we record different
people speaking so that room in which we
did this recording is about a third of
this or even maybe a fifth of this room
size it's a small conference room and we
had two sources speaking simultaneously
and our goal was to essentially find the
reflections which corresponded to each
source use the spherical array and point
the beam for the direct at the location
of interest and also find those
reverberant reflections which are
visible to the array and which
correspond to the source of interest and
clean up the sound while suppressing the
other sound and simultaneously d
reverberating ok so so the first thing
we needed was we needed a mechanism to
figure out which reflections correspond
to source a and which reflections
correspond to the distracting source and
to do this we need to sort of build a
similarity function which essentially
looks at the beam form signal coming
from the source of interest and all
reflections and see if these come from
the same source or they come from a
different source so we used mfcc
features to do that so and so here is
sort of images from the audio camera and
this is with the image is corresponding
to one source the image is corresponding
to the second source and the image is
corresponding to the when both sources
are present and on the Left we are
showing the mfcc similarity metric which
is computed on the beamformer output ok
and the right to
panels correspond to that similarity
metric applied to the image when we we
have both sources present so essentially
when we had both sources present the
beam for the image should have looked
something like this but we are able to
suppress the these are these other
reflections and only have those
reflections which correspond to the
female alone and similarly for the male
we are able to suppress the female
reverberations on and get those
reverberations which correspond to the
mail guy so this this image is this
image is the audio camera image this is
for the male alone sorry for the female
alone for the male alone and this is for
both of them other lighter reflections
reflection and and here this is the now
we run this mfcc similarity guy for each
for a for every direction and it tells
us this location dislocation dislocation
in this location and this location are
the locations of the reflections for the
female and we run so this is this was
run first on the case where we had the
female alone and now we ran it also on
the case where we had both the female
and male speakers and we are still able
to sort of local locate the reflections
which correspond to the female and
likewise we did it for the male alone
and for the mail in the presence of the
female and again we are able to locate
the reflections which correspond to the
male speaker so now since we know so the
idea of the algorithm is we beam form to
not only the the source but also to the
location
of the peak of of the similarity metric
and now we are going to do delay and
some beamforming but for the beam form
signals from the spherical image output
is Franco yeah we are using you know the
regular arrangement it is mercy that
need to be I don't know but this is a
very good question and this this is
actually hot of the presses this is what
we did last month so I'm just and we
also in the during the course of this
research we also developed a very good
time delay estimator and now we are sort
of checking how good because it works
very nicely in reverberant environment
for performing sort of delay and some
beamforming we need to figure out the
delay between the reflected image
sources and so here is sort of the
single-channel source this is the after
the doing the approximate match filter
our process and this is the original and
we get significant improvement at least
to perceptual quality but we need to run
some more tests to to sort of give you
quantitative say pest scores or
something like that to tell you how much
improvement we've had okay so now let's
sort of look at the evolution of the
hardware so that if we want to use this
guy and we want to sort of have many
people use this guy we need to give it
out in a portable format and have it go
around so the first one we built I said
is this very color a and you can see the
amount of wires coming out from each of
the microphones sort of here and of
course the hemispherical array was nice
because we had all the hole in the table
we could sort of take this huge braid of
wires and take it but this makes the
whole thing very unported so you want to
get it portable so
about 2007-2008 we try to develop a
portable version and this is a
32-channel array which we develop and we
moved all the analog to digital
conversion electronics into the center
of the ball and so this guy just has one
power and 11 USB wire coming out of it
and there is some FPGA stuff going on
there which essentially takes all the
analog to digital and packs it into USB
and sends it out which channels in one
wire and now we may be samples per
second yeah and use 16 bits we this one
is 12 bits but we can we could do to
point but we we are actually using very
small percentage of the available
bandwidth so we can go to 256 if we
wanted microphones are 24 bits and that
so so now then the version we developed
earlier end of last year is now 64
channels so this is a five and a half
inch sphere and it has one camera which
is which is also built into it so this
is a single USB camera and this is what
so this is a camera looking out we can
look out with this and now we sort of be
licensed the design to a company in our
area and these guys actually now
building an array which has six cameras
which sort of stitch panoramas at the
same time as they are sort of taking the
panoramic audio images and so you can
sort of and it's much more rugged these
guys they sort of built enclosures and
so on they and they are trying to ramp
up and try to sell these things
to the radius is about 5.8 engines which
is about our yes
they can do it smaller too but this is
there so I sort of started a few minutes
early i'll just sort of finish by sort
of saying some other applications of the
spherical array which we are doing one
is we are also want to use it for remote
reality reproduction so we want to
essentially capture reality at some
point say take you in a concert hall and
then have the ability to place you in
that concert hall so we capture this
this spherical array sound then we do
what's convert the sound field into a
plane wave representation so we know the
plane waves which are sort of impinging
at that location and now if I know your
head related transfer function I can
place you at that location by taking
those plane waves and convulsing them
with your head related transfer function
so so that's and then this is the scene
recording skin playback we so as far as
head related transfer functions are
concerned these are sort of things so
I'm just going to sort of skip very
quickly to this thing so it turns out
that human beings when we hear sound we
don't hear the actual source sound the
sound which is actually received at I
ears so if this is the envelope of the
frequencies of the sound which was sort
of from the source the sound which is
actually received at your ear is quite
different because some frequencies are
enhanced and some are attenuated because
of the process of scattering of your own
body and so you are changing the color
of the sound ok so when you are changing
the color of in light this would be like
taking a CD and moving it in light you
will get lots of colors in light because
the wavelengths of light correspond to
the sort of bumps on the surface of the
CD so you get these color shimming so
just like that when you move in sound
you are changing the color of the sound
which is coming knew nothing
and the interesting thing is that this
process of changing the color of the
sound which is different for every
person so every person has changes the
color of the sound which is received
differently and this gives you sort of
additional cues to do source
localization and if I want to reproduce
virtual reality and I want to sort of
give you very stable source locations in
sort of audio presentation over
headphones I need to know this transfer
function for every individual and this
measuring this transfer function if say
and every individual ear shapes are
different and so the transfer function
is different for every person and
measuring this transfer function used to
be a relatively tedious affair what you
would do is you would sort of take
speaker play a chirp from one location
then play a chart from another location
another location and so on and you would
sort of do it this over two hours and
maybe a thousand directions and that
would give you this head related
transfer function but we use an idea
which is all often used in vision also
which is called hell molds reciprocity
and what this principle states is
suppose I have a sound source at a given
location let's say here and I have a
receiver here if I swap the location of
the source and the receiver I will get
the same measurement at the receiver
location so this is sort of showing you
that in simulation even though the
overall acoustic field will be totally
different between the two points there
will be this principle of reciprocity so
we use this idea to create to measure
head related transfer function in few
seconds so the idea is we place
headphone drivers turned out in people's
ears we use that microphone array which
you saw in the background
and we record the received signal for
all directions in one shot as opposed to
sort of doing direction x direction
recording and we can get this head
related transfer function and if we
compare the head related transfer
function measure the two ways we get the
same thing so this is some related to
sort of scene reproduction work we also
do sort of computation of head related
transfer function computation of
scattering so now we are developing sort
of arrays which are not necessarily
spherical shape but say head shaped or
other shapes up suppose I put
microphones on some arbitrary scattering
object like a robot a network of
microphones how can I beam form with
those microphones so then I would have
to solve the wave equation to get those
beamformer weights and are we working on
those but we going sort of too many
different directions so i think i just
take this opportunity conclude and thank
you all for inviting me here you are you
yeah so you can peep is too long it's up
we actually what we did is we first seen
the year okay yeah and then put the
speakers but but since this is a sort of
important question what we did is we
also put a microphone we took a dummy
head and we put a microphone inside the
dummy head and thus the sealed apparatus
and we sort of checked what is the DB
level of the sound and it was only 65 DB
which is much lower than any even sort
of it's like conversational speech level
so this was otherwise you know it would
be wonderful you can measure everyone's
head related to and so functions but
they are there but they're all deaf at
the end of the procedure which is so
like very bad of this gif its main leave
an hour for java sea of your yes also
some use in algeria almost entirely
geometry little bit little bit of
material with your message on see it's
stuck percolator or skills yeah
so I'll give you away with it as a
message ology of this prison here you
can do that we can compute it is but
it's complications is relatively
expensive stems yeah first you and then
you okay so I'm wondering about the
spherical right now it's like 60 for
minor concert right but like eight by a
planar you can do the same kind of
processing and create those same kind of
images the only thing is especially with
these weird geometries if you put it
near the wall or if you have so you have
all these edge effects and to sort of
get reliable beam weights to get sort of
the same gain in each direction and so
on it's harder to do with regular arrays
so for example edge array the edge
microphones have different weights those
kinds of things so there are there are
constraints but in principle if you
could compute easily the beam weights
corresponding to each direction you can
use any procedure to create new symmetry
so the the spherical array buys you this
sort of nice mathematical framework to
get the more I guess yeah for you yes I
was like the farm it's very similar to
Fourier up here
like I was easier it's easy to think
about the spacing between microphones
being you know like big spacing that
it's going to have a title that is that
is correct so for example if I have if I
have more microphones on my array I can
go to higher order and I can get tighter
beams so for example when we went from
the 64 microphones on the hemisphere we
got 128 microphones so we could sort of
get order eight beams out of that that
set up whereas the regular 64 microphone
array we could only get order six beams
so that's which are how tight there okay
so this is the the demo I was trying to
show you which sort of died this is the
atom any sort of pan around the room so
this is the room in which we need the
experiment for this is a so what we did
is the experiment had two speakers and
we played timet database frames oh it
was all cued up okay so here is the room
you can sort of there's a table in the
middle so it has a very complex
structure so if you wanted to estimate
the impulse response using simple
geometry or so on it would be very hard
so now play a sound source so this is
one yeah so that's one speaker playing a
sound source you can sort of see it's
reflecting of the table of the wall of
the side wall there is a second order
reflection in that wall of the
whiteboard and so on they're all these
reflections so the goal is of that idea
of some how to use these reflections to
to do both d reverb and clean up the the
room is about this direction 24 feet and
widthwise it's about 11 feet
so this this dimension is 11 feet and
this dimension along the table is about
24 feet this is also continuous sound so
this is continuous sound because the
sound is sort of pumping into the room
it's not a chirp it's a continuous
speech continuously it's it's it's
continuous noise so everyone if you can
see that part importunate this
resolution you can't see the plot /
showing in this particular images just a
high frequency say 4000 kilohertz band
performed on the parts and and so you
see in the energy is that when the
energy happens to drop off there is sort
of randomly generated signal that's when
you start to see the reflections in the
room so unfortunately can't see that
plot at all
Lloyd you'll see it'll have sort of
short bursts and say five or ten
millisecond square the energy and the
4,000 Hertz band has dropped off and
that's sort of these points where you
see the reflections come so the of
course speech when people speak there is
sort of interruptions and so on but at
the same time it's it doesn't decay like
in the other case because the person
keeps repeating sweet so it is only you
know five years across
something's across the right so if it's
a continuous sound why aren't we just
seeing it amid from the direct and then
see the look it you do see the direct
path so you can see the Drake Pat go off
and come on go off and come on this is
not real hot Renesys no no this is it
very slow so check this one out motion
yeah so why do we see the direct path
the law because the that speech segment
got over oh it's speaking it speech
segment okay
it would be a little more clear if they
hadn't chopped the graph on the top of
the energy but
horse Agatha try and use this
programmable resolution
breakfast is it it's easier to be just a
short term tonight and then share with
this fear the yet but the chart gives
you the impulse response but it's sort
of what this was actually the if you
played a sharp of course you could
either use that to identify the impulse
response yes yeah you could do that but
this so the goal here was not to do that
the goal was to say suppose we just take
this device and we know nothing about
that thing we don't have the ability to
play chirps we don't have any career
error how can we clean up the speech and
record
so the reverberation time of that we
didn't get into the river agent yeah is
about to it was about to 200 300 300
milliseconds but because the signal was
was sort of continuous you always see
something being image whether be actual
direct Great War reverberations okay
look like any we didn't see a lot of
color from other places so yeah most of
it was the director if you look at sort
of the accumulation over a short period
of time that's when you get the image
from the previous so you can sort of see
the other side where you get sort of the
spots that correspond tax or reflections
become persistent if you sort of average
these images over and keep a running
average that you can see where all the
peak locations are actually accumulated
acuity and that's what we use in
I'm actually see the things aren't just
sort of becoming and Ian no
reverberation right that's right i mean
presumably if you played us like saying
like a quick impulse mood to your decay
some level of aliens but would have a
much quicker than the course in the
conference yeah and at the same time if
you played some continuous noise in then
you you may see all these sort of
standing waves develop and so on that
also we didn't do
I mean this comes of you
you have the identified but reaching for
a vicious vicious operation Frank you
don't get any power which source comes
from fighting them excessively she was
like so if there are other people going
to hear ya so we only tried so far with
two sources and we are able to
distinguish the reflections of the two
sources
it is like a usually female oh yeah oh
yeah listen yeah the easiest of course
yeah yeah and so of course there are
many people who are sort of researched
so we would have to build stronger
matrix which are not based on just mfcc
maybe something else but anywhere this
is but this is sort of well-studied
field we have to borrow their ideas but
this is just a first posture yes well
this might be far away as a camera
if you also have so we are working on
some concept which is the focus the
focal length of course is the sort of
the radius of the array which is the but
we are working your question is sort of
interesting can for example can we build
a telephoto lens for this camera and we
are working on some ideas like that
trying to see if we can so that's work
in progress if it happens we will sure
yeah you mentioned that the company's
product of this so the they are going to
build 5 next month the first five units
will be built next month and then they
have sort of two or three potential
customers if they are able to sell to
those they will continue building here
otherwise yeah
yeah so out of that device are you going
to get the screen channels or older
villar processing so that device is just
going to send you in a USB the two USBs
so one will have the image stream which
is the camera camera and the other will
have the sound which is sort of pact
channel by channel in the computer then
will be the processing image
yep just make sure the Sun we're doing
this very cool just kidding transfer
function for the direction to that one
yeah I'm essentially supply that
right so the no actually not transfer
function what we are doing is we are
doing so for example because we have the
image channel so the way this would be
used with actual speaker is we reduce a
weed run a phase detector we'd know by
the phase detector what are the
locations of the people resources yeah
so then once I know the primary
direction of the source I take the beam
form sound from that direction how do
you get it using the spherical array and
the knowledge of the source location
while using the certification sent
resuscitation have the geometry of the
thing yeah so what did you so now I run
my spherical area beamformer this very
this w wait those w wakes with those
they are based on plane wave scattering
of the spherical array from that
particular direction essentially so that
is this is equal to zero
the particular microphones that I have a
game
great then you invert that precise from
that direction I know that solution for
that direction and liberation is two
ways we don't need to calibrate too much
if you calibrate so for example that
there are some Corrections we could
apply so these sources these weights
correspond to infinite too far field
weights if you want you can sort of
correct those weights for near-field
weights and there are procedures to do
that but we don't do that okay I mean
yeah so if you're sort of within those
weights you the corrections would have
to happen for our sort of size array if
you closer than a meter to the net if
you're more than a meter away you can
still use the the far field weights all
right
sorry correct again today we would have
to correct both the gain an offense but
the correction so there are this
question has been studied a lot in the
literature forehead related transfer
function because this is exactly the
same thing again we in which is studied
which is measured in those in that
context and it turns out that there are
approximate geometric expression you can
get how to correct the phase how to
connect so how to correct the gain both
but if you are but if you're beyond a
meter and our our sphere is about head
size if you are beyond a meter you're
you're you don't need to correct those
or it's sort of less than so many DB
whatever